so the question is this why are my
thyroid hormones not working I've seen
people that are uncensored for 20 years
they're still tired they're still fat
it's not working the doctors saying well
keep taking it because maybe if you
didn't take it you would get even bigger
and then also why could you have all the
thyroid symptoms yet nothing shows up in
a blood test why is that well that is
because the problem is not in the
thyroid so when you solve the wrong
problem especially if you're taking
thyroid medication is not working you
won't see change so just realize you
have to think outside the box and look
at other possibilities there is two
common problems that are underneath I
write issues that are very very very I
guess unknown number one it's a
situation we have low bile B I le2
interferes with the conversion through
the liver in other words bile is the
detergent that breaks down the grease
and helps you digest fats it's made by
the liver it's stored in the gallbladder
and it comes right through and so let's
I write inactive hormone called t4
that's the inactive version converts
from to a t3 which is right here with
the help of bile so without my nut biome
let's say you're bloated and you're
constipation or you have the gallbladder
removed we have a sluggish liver or you
have a right shoulder pain or headaches
whatever all those are indications of
low bile
chances are you're not converting this
situation so this is what you need to
strengthen not the thyroid and then
offset it starts working okay then the
other situation is an ovary that's
producing too much estrogen why because
when you spike the estrogen you shut
that thyroid thing down and then what
happens you treat the symptom which is
the thyroid and you don't see any change
because the real problem is deeper now
why don't the doctors look at this
because it's very difficult to detect it
on testing and it's these are called sub
clinic
they don't show up so you really have to
use symptoms to figure it out I mean my
whole thing is hey if you took some bile
salts or you took something to kind of
help the ovary and you get better I
don't need to do a test we know that was
it I mean I don't have to wait for it to
show up on some liver enzyme test or
some other blood test because a lot of
these problems don't show up on blood
tests till they're very very very
advanced okay so I'm just trying to
increase your viewpoint on everything
works together and the thyroid is
usually a secondary problem to these
other two situations